what's going on guys this is Rob and
this bumper is to let you guys know that
we are having a Super Smash Brothers
tournament this weekend on Saturday on
the discord server if you guys don't
know about it I have a discourse server
for all the comments explained fans we
have quizzes we have all kinds of
tournaments games things for you guys to
do and once every month we actually have
a kind of vs. battle of source where we
give away a Rob core ring so if you guys
want to be a part of that make sure you
guys check the link down in the
description it'll be a permanent link to
the discord service you'll always have
access and yeah hopefully I'll see you
there let's begin okay so a lot of you
guys have been asking my opinion on
Justice League dark apocalypse war and
and to be honest with you guys I did not
initially see it when it dropped right
at me as far as I'm aware I think it
dropped at the beginning of May I didn't
see it until last night and a lot of
guys been asking about it Sol's like
okay so I sat down with Mariah she and I
checked it out and and here's the thing
we loved it right like we loved it and
here's the funny thing about it and this
is what I don't really understand what I
mean I've noticed in recent years that
Warner Brothers animation has kind of
been ticking up on the number of
animated films they've been releasing
but it's one of these things where like
Warner Brothers seems to put a lot more
emphasis behind their their extended
universe tried their live-action films
that they do their animated films and
it's kind of a shame because every
animated film they've made has been
better than their live-action films like
that be my emphasis why did that be mine
my decision like I would focus on the
animated side you know like I would
focus on like these animated movies and
just create a cohesive universe out of
that right I mean people people's you
know what will say things like well it's
a cartoon so it can't really be taken as
serious or anything like that but like
we just spent 10 years watching a movie
about a guy who was frozen in ice for 70
years coming back a god who eats apples
and basically keeps himself essentially
immortal a scientist who turns into a
giant greed green rage monster and an
archer who was somehow able to fight
like a god deity kind of guy right like
a demigod so like we're way beyond the
point where anybody can make an argument
of saying that like it would be too
cartoony right like that's that's kind
of nonsense but you know that the movie
was absolutely fantastic it was amazing
and he know to reminds me of you know
wonder eyes enough it reminds me of of
Days of Future past
that's how it felt right it felt like
Justice League data through your past
now as far as I'm aware and this is kind
of the cool thing right so spoilers you
know going forward for you know the
movie if you haven't seen it you know
this looks like it takes place basically
in the future of the flashpoint universe
right because from what we saw like
flashpoint happened right you have like
John Constantine you know who basically
uses his powers on Berry and then
realizes that berry caused flashpoint
right and the berry goes back and
basically undoes flashpoint in order to
keep this from happening right so it's
like the the finality of the flashpoint
universe which is cool you know it's
it's cool we'll get to that here in a
second but the funny thing is that the
movie picks up right with this idea that
like Darkseid's basically launched an
invasion against earth twice we've seen
that play out you know in different
circumstances and so it's this idea that
basically the Justice League is kind of
going on the defensive right the dark
side just kind of like popped in
released some drones and then popped out
with the intention of basically
recounting the area and then launching
an attack right he knows kind of viewed
as a prelude to an attack
and so then you basically go into the
Justice League launching their strike
and this was a little bit disappointing
to me because what I was hoping is we
would see this full-on fight instead you
have the Justice League that shows up to
apocalypse or immediately attacked by
parademons and then you just pick up two
years later and it's like okay so like I
don't know how I feel about that right I
don't feel about that that whole thing
but you know whatever we kind of get
flashbacks and we get the full
explanation of what goes on it was one
of the coolest things about this and
it's what I loved about it like it's not
one of these things where like everybody
lives happily ever after right like they
make it out by the skin of their teeth
but they make it out like Superman gets
injected with liquor ooh liquid with
kryptonite so he loses his powers
Batman is put in the Mobius chair by
Darkseid which is kind of cool to see
them revamp it but basically he's kind
of turned into like this injustice
Batman from like if Superman just kind
of continued on and then one where he's
basically mind controlled by dark side
you've got cyborg who's the whole reason
why the plan failed because Darkseid was
spying on the Justice League through him
and knew exactly what their plan was
going to be by the time they got there
and he's basically turned into like the
source wall more or less is you know for
apocalypse anyway is kind of how it's
explained is I'm still a little murky on
the role that he played you got Martian
Manhunter
you've got Hawkman and you've got Queen
Mara who were basically turned into
Furies alongside Wonder Woman who leads
them all which can we just admit
Wonder Woman as a fury facing off
against Etrigan
amazing it was like the coolest thing
ever right um there were some amazing
moments in this movie one of the things
that I really wish we could have seen
and we didn't get to see it but one of
the things that I really really wish we
could have seen was the actual fight
between Darkseid and what was left of
the Green Lantern's right because we
only got a couple of them we got like
Kilowog who died like that we got you
know a few others here and there like
Jon Stewart gets incinerated he had a
really epic moment but it would have
been cool to actually see Darkseid fight
like the guardians of the universe right
and like overtakes them that would have
been awesome to see I feel like that was
a missed opportunity but at the same
time if for no other reason than pacing
it probably just didn't work right
probably we just didn't didn't really
fit into you well but I think it would
have really solidified like what the
Justice League was facing facing off
against it's right because the reality
is that looking at the movie looking at
how they all failed it didn't really
look like they failed because of just
the power of Darkseid it looked like
they failed because Darkseid knew what
their plan was right so it was just
ingenuity and and good thinking on his
part it's really all it was as opposed
to like Darkseid being presented as this
almost just like intimidating you know
unstoppable immutable force of like evil
with that throughout the entirety of all
existence right throughout the entirety
of the multiverse um I think that came
into play later on with with dragon but
it was a cool it was it was cool right
because you get things like Damien's
leaving the League of Shadows now and
like Nightwing you know he tried to
resurrect Nightwing to the Lazarus pits
and Nightwing was just permanently
insane but you got these really really
awesome these really really awesome
things but this that's kind of what I
loved is like it just felt it lived up
to its name right Justice League dark
the movie felt dark it felt like a
worst-case scenario
to be honest with you guys and that's
why I say it felt like Days of Future
past because you know kind of a
sidetrack here at the time that x-men
Days of Future past was released right
uncanny x-men 141 142 you had some
comics that kind of led up to that but
that was the worst case scenario for the
x-men and in the x-men's comics and even
within Marvel as a larger entity we'd
never really seen anything like that
right we're like some force popped up
and basically killed or enslaved all the
super heroes and super villains and all
those who powers and even humans across
North America we'd never really seen
that before
and so it was it was pretty like
mind-boggling to see just how bad
things were for everybody in that story
and with this film it felt so much like
that right and one of the coolest things
about this was the character of Raven
but I loved the way they played with
Raven because my initial thought is
because you kind of had this like tug
right you've basically got Raven who's
got not that you're gonna got tried and
locked away and it's one of these things
where try game is always trying to
escape but as the movie starts to get
towards his end it's almost like trigons
on her side right like just like the
what is the point where they're in their
own apocalypse you know when they're
being hit by like all these lasers and
things like that and you know so on and
trigons just like just let go like trust
me I will make sure you survive and then
he does like right here like he
basically saves her she channel's the
power of try again he saves her and
everybody else there and then she goes
back to her to her normal self and like
that was cool to see that was a really
cool thing um I did like the romance
between between Raven and and Damian the
issue with that and I think that's one
of the things that you kind of ran into
with the issues of Damian in the movie
is the the things that you saw with his
character only really resonated if you
were a fan of Damian Wayne like if
you've been reading DC Comics if you
read Grant Morrison's run and you read
like Batman and Sun or something like
that Batman and Robin different things
like that you know where you had like
these stories of Damian in the bat
family then like the movie rings it
really changes the way you see Damian
especially when he jumps in the way of
Darkseid's Omega beams and then dies or
presumably seems to die for Batman of
course he didn't die he was just aged up
or something like that and then you know
it was you know and we'll talk about
what happened next year in a minute but
it's interesting Damian was one of those
those things were it seemed Warner
Brothers animation was really kind of
relying on one that you knew he was
Batman's son which they also kind of
reiterated that but then too you
understood the relationship between the
two of them they did a pretty good job
of saying things like well you know he's
into you you know like like Batman
saying like you were a mistake and your
mom drugged me in order to have you and
her you know and all I kind of stuff but
like a lot of that's more impactful if
you're familiar with the comic books and
so I wouldn't go as far as to say they
could have done a better job and how
they handled Damian they did great it's
just that the impact and the
significance of his character it hits
you harder if you've read the comics
right so watching how everybody felt
right like Starfire being a being a fury
like the Teen Titans we're just
almost totally obliterated right like
Superboy basically like he barely made
it out by the skin of his teeth it's
never really explained I don't think if
it's Conner Kent or Jonathan Kent I'd
like to believe it's Jonathan Wright
because I feel like it makes the stakes
of Superboy surviving even more
important because I love the character
of Jonathan as opposed to you know the
character of Conner I didn't grow up
with Young Justice so I was never really
a counter Kent fan the fact that
Superboy ends up biting the bullet later
on anyway you know it's one of those you
know one of those things but still you
know it was it was cool but for the
character of Raven you know her kind of
kind of doing her thing and you know and
and constantly struggling to keep trying
at BAE I think was a really good way to
eliminate the MacGuffin of like we'll
just have Raven fix it cuz she channel's
the power of a god so like she can just
solve everything I think was a great way
to nip that in the bud right for anybody
who would go into it asked me the
question well just let Ravens demigod
powers save the day to immediately take
that out of the equation and say yeah
but if she cuts loose
Trigon breaks free he'll kill Damien and
destroy the world right so it's like
okay so let me kind of have to keep that
whole thing going if I'm being honest
with you guys
the standout star of the whole movie it
wasn't Superman or any of those guys the
standout star John Constantine he was
amazing in this movie it's crazy how
good his character is and here's a funny
thing I'm more of a fan of Constantine
now than I've ever been after seeing
this movie because like like the
struggle his character goes through it's
awesome because after that great big
huge event that went on with like the
defeat of the Justice League and all
that kind of stuff like it was one of
these things where he was depicted as a
coward because when you've got him as
etana as a couple and cetanas like
overtaken by all these these you know
these parademons which turn out to
basically just be like Doomsday's who
have just been cruel one created by
Darkseid and apparently the doomsday
that killed Superman was created by dark
side and then turn into parademons at
the same time when she's like overtaken
by all these these Perry dooms as they
called them and then like she's
basically killed off it's this is thing
where like Constantine just runs and
it's just like okay so like that plays
perfectly into the nature of Constantine
right like he's not a fighter he's a
thinker right like he'll fight if he has
to but like he goes and usually does his
own thing and Cosentino only cares about
himself and so that fit in perfect
because you looked at that and and my
thought was okay
it seems a little shifty that he would
just bail like that but it also sounds
like something constantine would do
right like like the whole the whole
scenario the whole context was he was
scared but in Constantine doesn't
usually ever get shaken or rattled like
that at least nothing I'm aware of but
then you end up finding out later on
that the Etana was the one who did that
right cetana was the one who basically
cast a kind of spell that sent him
running right that basically made him
leave it he didn't know that was the
case that she kind of manipulated it you
know the entire way because she knew how
important he was going to be later on
down the road but also loved him right
and wanted to make sure that he lived
and so he does prove to be probably the
most important person in the entirety of
the of the film he's basically the one
with the plan he's the one that kind of
saves a day all that sort of good stuff
right but there were some other really
good things - right like the Suicide
Squad Harley Quinn Suicide Squad was
amazing and I'm so glad to see that they
didn't pull any punches right like they
were they were brutal he had king shark
who's just eating people like there's
one scene when they're fighting in the
prison he bites their heads off but he
literally see him by the guy's head off
right like you know when they're like we
need to take this truck and like he just
rips him apart and there's just blood
going everywhere it was cool to see that
right like the The Suicide Squad in that
movie I want to see that I want to see
more of that Suicide Squad
it was great like it was absolutely
awesome the fact that Harley Quinn is
leaving the team because Amanda Waller
died of cancer that's a great twist
right that's a really really really
great idea um lex luthor kind of threw
me off when Lex Luthor was talking to
Batman when you first introduced to your
first introduced to him and he seems
kind of meek and he has like the bass
out of his voice right to kind of appear
more more docile to Batman I thought it
was just playing at gambit right and we
go back to like the deep voice Lex
Luthor you know and like he's just
basically tricking Batman and lying to
him and that kind of a thing
it's not the case right he's still he's
really just kind of defeated and very
much a coward but ultimately ends up
being the one who was passing
information to Lois Lane who ends up
sacrificing her life you know in order
to save the day but like there was there
were some cool moments where I let like
this movie was was absolutely stellar
right the idea that Damian Wayne
basically ends up dying when he's hit by
the Omega beams or it looks like Raven
thinks he died when he was hit by the
Omega beams from Darkseid like she loses
control over keeping tryin you know
contained Trigon breaks free Constantine
tries to make himself a physical body
for try again and then tried and Bond's
himself to Superman which looked
incredible and then brushes Darkseid
like it was it was nuts I mean like like
watching it like watching try and fight
Darkseid was amazing it was one of the
coolest things it's like one of those
stories you never get right it's like
when we're doing infinity conflict like
what is it it was an infinity ending
like the next video we do will be Thanos
fighting the one above all and it's it's
cool to see like those crazy situations
like those those crazy matchups that you
just never get to see but you've always
wanted to button so it was it was
awesome to see that go down but at the
end of the day you know Constantine
really kind of talks to Barry Allen it
says okay you know you have to go undo
flashpoint you have to create a second
flashpoint to undo this timeline and I
really hope it doesn't turn into a trend
where like they basically end up wiping
a time line in order to kind of start
over again
but it was a great thing right because
all this is kind of continued after
flashpoint and it's a great way to kind
of go back through and say okay now
we're gonna tell a different set of
stories and then we'll end that timeline
however it is we feel like ending that
timeline and it's a great idea right
because you just follow this pattern you
tell stories in a particular universe
where you bring in the JSA you tell
their stories maybe you give us
something akin to Justice League dark
but for the Justice Society of America
give us like Armageddon or something
along those lines but you get some
really really cool moments you know add
it out of this whole thing but my
thoughts on Justice League dark
apocalypse war absolutely amazing it's I
think it's probably the best of the DC
animated films with the exception of the
Dark Knight Returns and it's certainly
the it's certainly better than any of
the live-action films that Warner
Brothers has made so if I'm then I'd
focus on my animated side I wouldn't
focus on my live-action side I focus on
the animated movies and just run with it
just just go with it just release him
his full-length feature films right this
movie was an hour and a half long you
add in a few more scenes you're at two
hours you got a full-length feature film
albeit animated and at the end of the
day people don't care what form the film
takes so long as it's good right Disney
been making animated films for a hundred
years yes or targeted towards kids but
at the end of the day it works it's a
formula that works if people like it
they will continue to see it and that's
just really kind of how this goes so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys loved the movie as much as I did if
you guys are new here to come this
explain make sure you guys
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
you